the Joe Rogan experience tell me about
how you got injured I've had problems at
ten it's a few times I've had some weird
medical issues at different times like
things that most people wouldn't have
done here
like what the it's okay if we diverge
from injury to illness sure sure
well one time I was starving the time I
ate the weasels this was a protracted
starvation like I literally was having a
famine for a couple months where I was
always getting a little bit of food but
not enough how much weight did you lose
a lot I didn't have a scale right but I
got real skinny real skinny like first I
lost all my fat then I literally lost my
muscles and I got really weak I still
going out looking for food every day but
I couldn't go as far I couldn't climb
out the 5000 foot mountains anymore I
got that week and this is over months
over months Wow
didn't have enough food for a couple of
months and you couldn't fish this was in
the winter ice the ice is very thick
back then the ice used to get thicker
back then it is usually about four feet
of ice on a lake by late winter now I'm
some winters I've only had two and a
half feet but anyway I I would try
fishing but there's not that many fish
there this is a little Lake a mile
across isolated in the mountains the
fish that are in the lakes stay there
like they they're also smaller they
don't grow as fast you can expend a lot
of effort chiseling through remember I
don't have a power auger or anything
chiseling through three four feet of ice
trying to catch fish that are you know
this long and this big around so I was
you know trying to be as efficient as
possible I had out a lot of snares for
snowshoe hares they're not many
snowshoes there's not much small game
but I was catching a little bit every
day I'd like I'd get a grouse I would
get a ptarmigan I would get a rabbit but
I was I was gradually getting weaker and
thinner and weaker and thinner so what
happened to me health-wise though was
that eventually when I got food I just
ate as much as I could eat
for three or four days all I did was eat
sleep and [ __ ] literally and I got
refeeding edema whoa
which at the time I didn't recognize I
didn't even know what it was but you can
actually die if you repeat yourself too
fast like World War two when they were
liberating concentration camps soldiers
didn't notice they're given prisoners
all the food they wanted to eat and some
people got this refeeding edema to get
pulmonary edema and literally die Wow
and you know disaster relief people are
going to like famine areas and whatnot
they know about this now you can't give
people unlimited food I didn't know
about that so I got edema and it was
weird I just thought like I was getting
fat or something but I was actually
retaining fluids and I didn't find out
four months later I was talking to a
doctor about what happened to me so you
got refeeding edema so you were just
living with it yeah it didn't last that
long like I don't remember exactly how
long it lasted but within two weeks of
when I got food I was like all puffy and
I'm like what the hell's going on it
couldn't put on weight this fast but it
was actually just fluid that my body was
like my chest was I remember Sylvie
pushing on saying you're all like spongy
and I was like he hasn't that weird
because I had been like you know
how'd you face getting bones if I just
felt hungry still I was just well not
for two weeks but man four days all I
did was I'd eat until my stomach just
couldn't take anymore wow what did you
gotten is that when you had gotten the
caribou from nose that's when I got
store-bought I got store-bought food a
friend of mine flew in the the thing
that had happened was we had this
arrangement where somebody supposed to
come partway through the winter that we
knew that was going to bring in food and
and some supplies and I kept thinking
like I just want to survive I want to
get through it like my goals to live off
the land as much as I can and we got
this arrangement anyway Tim's gonna
bring us some supplies later in the
winter I'm just gonna see the best I can
do you know and I just kept going on
against small-game then what happened
was even when you got a plane coming
it's hard sometimes to get in up there
and also you know my friend was working
during the week he could only come on
weekends the weather was bad this
weekend and then he couldn't come and
maybe there was some other issue with a
plane or something he just kept getting
delayed and it got to be a real problem
finally I was like I sent him a message
on that Sat phone I was like hey Tim you
know like I'm starving up here I've been
living on muskrats and and snowshoe
hares and not enough of them you you got
to come next weekend or make sure
somebody else gets in here because I was
really worried about my health at that
point then he did get in there and he
dropped off all this food and I just
picked out Wow and I got refeeding edema
[Applause]